[Laughter]
yeah my inventory is full and full of
beans beets those are very different
things what's going on with that full of
beneaths you know well I definitely
remember what we were doing where we
were what our Quest was and how hot what
do you be quiet the quest is we're on a
raft of dying of starvation in the ocean
oh we have the nope I thought this was
the navigation computer it's a
juicer it's a juicer all right I forgot
juicer I made you guys for that juice
God it's been so long
oh my God people are watching at home
great all right I swear we we really try
to make these consistent and you know
bring content regularly it's I don't
know how it gets to this way you had to
get sick and go travel the world but
that was still a month and a half prior
to the last or after the last time we
played this excuse this man how are we
we keep being like we're gonna do this
because you know we need to tell people
about distractible distractible have you
heard it it's our podcast together if
you like this you'll love that how would
anyone know about distractible but for
these videos we put out so regularly
I've been telling everyone how there's
only so many distractible episodes
probably left because one of them that's
coming out sometime soon is going to be
the last one we are allowed to post
oh yeah you're right actually we will
get canceled soon so listen while you
can before it's gone you're listening
like man I wish I listened to this
sooner and it's like oh you should have
oh wait that thing that's like oh
distractible so cool to listen to It's
too cool for me actually it's pretty
good I just dropped the antenna and
receiver down there for I I forgot I had
that I don't know why I had that
actually and I need to search them up
for no particular reason would you like
them back no I don't have inventory for
it I'm trying to purchase medium plot
down
I'm a little low on planky spankies so
uh hopefully there's some wood on this
island that looks like there's a couple
trees how many plancks you need can we
no longer plant can we no longer plant
watermelon in a medium crop plot they're
full I thought you were doing a medium
plot I have been I can't plan anymore
wait you need seeds is that a seed or
actually oh you're right oh I'm water
right right right right right right
right right okay okay guys okay
watermelon no okay I'm not making fun of
you Mark I'm making fun with you
all right whatever guys you no longer
plant watermelon oh no
oh no it happens to the best of us it
does why did it happen to you what
happens to the worst of us more that
should have been obvious I feel oh the
bins when they're full oh no never mind
you're just in it
yeah we had a food chest uh this one's
by the food area is the food chest but
none of it's cooked you're gonna have to
cook some stuff and we need uh I need we
need more storage let me see if I can
make some we need a big grill we need
big grill we need big grill yeah we
really eat it
good thing I reinforced this yeah he
literally attacked the one of the three
reinforced ones
dropping anchor
what do we need from here whatever we
can we we always are running out of
metal and wood like we just need so much
more of that always I didn't mean to be
in the water uh there's no way out of
the water dude I'm dying all right uh
I'm gonna make their where's the food oh
they're in the middle right okay so I'm
gonna put another chest
uh by the creply and that'll be the food
one okay excellent excellent excellent
we got water Malone we got cocoa nuts we
got mangoes uh
um that's everything we've ever had I
broke my ax before I got enough flanks
to make any wax
I need planks buddy
yeah try walking on this wall
look at your feet
great trip did you check your feet Yes
yes thank you good good I didn't say
anything but in my head I was like
they'll know what I'm thinking thanks
buddy
uh-huh
um if I don't make it back someone will
save me right how would your it's such a
tiny Island how can you possibly die I
didn't go to the island I went swimming
I'm definitely not gonna save you then
afraid I didn't want to lose the creator
of things like seven cave mushrooms oh
damn it's sick we need cave mushrooms
two explosive Goose that's pretty good
oh yeah we actually do need that we do
need that 80 I regret mocking you now
I'm sorry what 80 rocks oh hey guys the
stuff I got I was looking at one of our
chests not my inventory
[ __ ] I may have gotten a potato from
that crazy wrong with you
like I've got these things yes you're
welcome I shall leave them in this chest
where I found them on our own craft look
we do our best here
hey this can be distractible this is uh
a gaming segment sponsored by
distractible yes yes of course you're
being paid by distractible Yes actually
we do distractible for fun Wade there's
no money in that right they charge way
too much for us to do these promotions
to us for us by us we should have
negotiated us a better deal for us yeah
from us you guys okay
I guess
us has problems maybe let's talk about
maybe I should be more communicating
maybe I guess us we how do you how do
you wow oh I found it I'm gonna transfer
the fish to the food chest
guys I can make a big grill maybe that's
so red what do you need to make nails I
have eight metal ingots you need scrap
metal to make nails son of a there's
some in the storage that I'm in right
now I'm just putting the iron ingots in
here oh I've got what I need I've got
what I need no I don't I don't have I I
don't listen to me uh nope yep um
I've got what I need I've got what I
need yep
look ah there it is
not cook them big fishes
whoa shark man why is the food chest
empty I moved it it's over by the the
under the stairs okay just screw this is
all right man it's all right kill the
shark get the water I'll get the meat
get the meat we need a bigger Grill to
cook uh this is a big grill I made big
grill oh you made the grill
I'll leave the other big fish in the in
the thing and I will go get the metal
sounds good sounds good we're doing
pretty okay on food if you do need some
there is like uh there's beets there's
raw beets for some reason we're out of
potato I think did someone cook I lost
all of the potatoes okay the potatoes
are now extinct I have 15 potatoes which
chest is the new food chest I'll go by
the staircase
you said that you know you did say that
out loud I just chose not to listen to
it with my ears that's okay oh my God I
just picked up a crate that had so much
stuff we already had in it wait I know
why you like this now yeah it's pretty
good very good it is pretty good you see
that feeling right there every time you
all mention how old we're getting that's
how I feel inside who's mentioning this
uh one of the people on distractible and
it's not me so I'm assuming
oh must be one of us must be
hey I found raw steak and berries in
this chest that's not the food chest
oh I remove it to the food chest okay
good do we need seaweed for stuff that's
the only thing we need we always think
so yeah
that's how we get the green goo right
that we use for for doing stuff
[Laughter]
I love that game dude YouTube is always
trying to get me to watch that I'll be
like show me some car videos or
something and YouTube is like Markiplier
played on the oxygen not included for a
year and a half ago
you want to watch that no man no I don't
not to Markiplier videos Markiplier is
not included damn it
attack me again
you really are the king of that game
Mark I am people always say that loud
and boisterously every game you've
played you're the king of yes obviously
pressure no not really when you don't
feel pressure yeah
it's fine
no I hate the taste
that's Mark's favorite game he's the
king of it
oh
oh these things weren't even cooking
yeah I know that game why is there a
starving was there a boot in the middle
of this nonsense not like that for me
because you could plant in it yeah but
it's in the middle of the nonsense yeah
it's a plant
well now I got a plan have you planted
it I I haven't I didn't I'm eating raw
potatoes is that efficient can you can
you bring the potatoes back so we can
well am I wasting our Resources by doing
this activity
those potatoes next to the watermelons
now you actually do plant whole potatoes
yeah no [ __ ] me well this is weird
Marcus the chef haven't I been the chef
for like almost all of us
I'm like I'm like the growing person I'm
not necessarily the chef but I'll be
here [ __ ] stuff over there I don't
know what the hell yeah I'm just here
yeah
it's kind of peaceful life it's chill
right I don't know what a flicked to do
with a sea Madness before but this is
lovely well I I bequote it to you
yeah but cool with you if I want to stop
a clothing all over I already did
I don't want to be clothed you're
already full of clothes don't fill me
with your clothes
you think you could just fill someone
with your cloth yeah or me haven't you
ever heard that personal quoth is a good
thing no
I feel oh okay wait watch out your heads
terrifying don't do that to me how did
you lose track of where you were and
existence wood everywhere
uh I kind of ran into a problem
um I realized yeah you made the stealing
one foot high yeah I realized I should
have put the support in one because then
it would have uh yeah this is a um
sure is
stop I did this terribly
listen guys you
all right I'm with you you listening
what am I listening for listen to that
sounds distractible
[Laughter]
the merch remember the merch Bob you
always remember the merch I think merch
is fool's errands I talk this way now
little words for me
the I explained sport like Tyler
Tyler sounds like e simplify for Mark
God damn
didn't think I'd hit you with the gmf
Tyler
did you I really enjoyed that that was
lovely yeah I brought your potatoes
thanks and pop them in the old food
chest there there's what there's no
organizational scheme I don't know why
I'm not yet eventually I'm going to try
when I make the second floor I'm hoping
that I can get some semblance of
organization here see what you're taking
that dude can I I'm all right I am
hungry is there a cooked food place yeah
I'm putting it all in the food chest for
now
um feel free to take uh pretty much
anything these beats are oh I'm full of
stuff no can I have this
car It's gotta be close to dead again
I've been stabbing this one a bunch
there's another I learned us a
motivational quote man I feel like we
had that like several times already I
killed other sharks the water is safe I
need to pick up some of this [ __ ]
because I need to move it around Be not
Afraid ye mere mortals I killed other
sharks the water is safe all right thank
you
I think I think
glass World taking attention this moment
I sure already charvested the whole left
side of the island all right
did my pants I'm sorry guys I know you
were sharper I already starved
oh man I'm so sorry I said no you guys
ever sharved
all the time all the time my guy I make
I'm doing I'm making a thing the
container are you moving these
containers should I leave these empty uh
you can do whatever you want really um
I'm making the container here by the um
by the smelters the like smelting crap
cool yeah I'm just trying to clear some
space so that I can um get the second
pillar move these pillars in one because
it's not building right without it and
eventually I'll just reorganize as I go
as well also I guess you sharved pretty
good I don't really see any metal yeah I
told you
while you can because I'm about to move
the water things so grab water if you're
thirsty cup of Reno
okay
[Music]
oh nice all right everyone got their
water good
nope all right
okay good good good anymore
well I don't have any
what do you mean what are you talking
about
wait what is a solid foundation have we
looked at this yeah I put a reinforced
Foundation near the the no no no no no
look at if you have a hammer look at the
foundations and mouse over the regular
foundation and there's one that's called
solid foundation which takes one more
wood and one more plastic that is not
the reinforced one I'm not even oh is
that new I mean probably not but that's
new to us right we've never actually
built anything a lot so options oh my
God you could just make us stronger
raise anchor let's get some material I
guess let's get ourselves wood oh man
we're so stupid anchors up Captain why I
didn't do it nor am I captain I'm just
gonna go over here
buddy I raised it and I said I raised it
I don't know how you got confused by
that wait if you want to help aim the
sale so we're going directly forward yes
uh we're going this way for now which
ways forward well it's getting us around
this work on the front of the boat
we need to get around the island I was
sort of thinking we didn't really get
around very effectively
I'm paddling up a storm paddle harder
all right I'm done paddling
fails
what I fell off the boat
trying to find out
I am I found myself I didn't need to
move that crop look
are these gonna work if there's a roof
over like a plant Stone yeah no yeah no
that totally works all right love to
hear this game don't have no sun
simulations uh no Optical bounces no Ray
tracing here wrath with Ray tracing give
it to me that would be dope as hell all
right the sun things is going back in if
you wanted water
[Music]
well we can get the like next one
soon and then we won't need these idiots
the next one is the pump and the okay
yeah we're not there yet yeah we're not
there yet we'll get there someday we're
actually trying to improve here it'll be
wonderful someday yep we'll definitely
get there we'll get there all right let
me continue building one out for the
homies that solid wooden floor who needs
that not us no everything except the
exterior that sharks can attack I got
them I got them I got them all right and
then we need plastic circuits
wait we have an antenna receiver in one
of the chests yeah oh do we yeah okay so
Mark when you're when you have it all
built I guess we'll put it in the easy
spot I mean you can feel free go ahead
upstairs that's that's most of the I'm
just trying to get more of the floor
built uh as soon as we get more wood on
the next pass
are there seeds in here oh [ __ ] I'll get
those those I'm sorry why are there
seeds in my smelting box oh geez oh wow
this is embarrassing
uh yep it is mostly for you so we're not
eating just to read just to reiterate
this we're not eating not eating not
eating wait a minute we are not eating
pomfrets or herrings please Gentlemens
all right you heard the man that's what
we use is to making the shark baits
shark bait uh what am I doing my life
I don't know what are you doing with
your life my inventory is empty and yet
somehow I still feel like I I have
nothing and I can't put anything
anywhere what why am I overwhelmed this
game is not hard that is a question that
many people in the comments have asked
for a very long time about us playing
this game why am I so overwhelmed with
this it's not complicated hey guys I got
the fireplace recipe hey finds a way
life fire finds a way oh no
oh is there a way to split Stacks in
this game
uh
oh you right click
yes
oh my God there's so many barrels ahead
of us and they're all gonna hit our Nets
oh my gosh oh my God guys yeah
that is a lot of barrels you just throw
our ingots on the ground no
oh okay good because I thought that's
what it looked like you did of course it
looked like that
you would never lie to me no no no no no
I love the way your inflection goes when
you tell me the truth
[Laughter]
these are there we have a whole thing
with leaves we've got a lot of Leafs
yeah
are there seeds in with the leaves don't
put the seeds I'm trying please go with
seeds Mark are you done
with the radio I haven't even gotten it
happens why aren't you done oh I feel
memories flooding back into Me From
Another Universe
because he's over here stealing barrels
that's why oh yeah you're gonna stop me
big boy huh no you can prevent this oh
man I'm bent over to haul this big one
inside of a shark eating us God as far
as it sounds something something oh
hello you guys want to see me get a
barrel hello
oh yeah
I got one
neither one of us are looking at Bob but
okay
what are you doing something Bob I would
look I don't have no Fishing Baits all
right hey the Watermelons are done
bad news no seeds on that one I I have a
fishing pole because I just made it do
you want a fish wave because I feel like
I've done that quite a bit yeah if you
want to take a break for fishing I'll
fish that's fine here uh please don't go
in the ocean fish lad all right I'm
gonna eat that salmon fish fish lemonade
and I'm gonna put this potato in with
the potatoes round of the corner
oops turns out it's Gatorade
always has been what whoa God graphical
glitch what the [ __ ] was that wait you
don't come over to this corner much do
you
no I didn't even know we had a corner
over there okay Bob you don't go there
what what does that mean that you didn't
no that's fine you didn't know that we
had a quarter over there
corner I thought a raft was a circle I
think we were talking in non-euclidean
terms
okay well all right
I was so hyped about the Box situation
and then it just is ripped away you
could have the decorative package please
take it come on sure sure hey I got us a
world globe wow I got you another
package thanks
I'm starving to death amazing how that
maybe you should have kept the beat
maybe that's salmon that I got in my
inventory to eat I should have eaten hmm
that sounds stupid yeah stupid sharks
are both to be wider sexier naked
and a freighter
okay okay go on
no choose bait I have no bait it's a
bait new the it's that's the traitors
thing you need the bait to catch exotic
fish to trade into the traders to
increase your reputation with the
Traders the Traders are on the the
Traders are on like the big like Quest
Island type places yeah what he said
that I also knew but didn't we craft
them I knew it but I kept it to myself
yeah just to stick it to you I'm a
mysterious greedy man
well maybe yeah would I do that I don't
know who knows not me
leaves I want to tear you apart
[Laughter]
good I got a candle bottle I'm a great
fisherman
thanks wait are you prepared for oh I
don't know if I have enough flanks for
this anymore I don't well I'm trying to
grab as many planks as I can are there
any stored planks no I've been running
on empty on me here Bobby never mind we
missed an island with the left well it's
just a dingo Island do we really need it
I don't know I think right now we need
resources
we need metal and stuff yeah
all right I'm putting the beds up here
on the second floor where the rain can
really splash down on our faces as we
sleep I love a refreshing sleep
it's gonna be extra moist up here guys
wow this is pretty perfect oh hey that
corner that you said not to go to I just
scared another bird away from that
that's all right
I somehow accounted for you going over
there excellent that sounded both mean
and smart I like it
me too all right painting
and table that's Andy nice
we could have a real home yet stop good
stuff good stuff are you trying to
expand your second floor Mark uh I'm
about hit where I wanted to expand it
um and then I'm gonna start filling it
up with more stuff up here
he's attacking the Invincible one again
I don't idiot a raw herring
hair hair
oh it was funnier in my head than it was
now no you know what good good joke
buddy oh we got a we got a raft to the
right I forget what those usually have
on them but it's not too far it's got
good Racers usually uh I'll guide us I'm
steering never mind I'm way way later no
no no no no no you go ahead after you I
am free okay guys one of you [ __ ] do
it this is what happens when there's no
Captain Chaos
whoa there's something underwater
jellyfish dude whoa oh there are
they probably are friendly and wouldn't
hurt us I want to see don't die don't
die don't die don't get stuck These are
nice jellyfish I think okay that's so
cool that's pretty I think the shark's
still alive
well maybe
he was what do you know all right uh my
inventory is full of you you go oh God I
am the adventurer
you know yes all right repointing us
forward what did we get off the raft
anything good uh no just random
resources nothing nothing crazy oh I
Just Had a Brain Blast
spring blast yeah pretty blessed
sponsored butt wait is that this thing
oh it sounds like a Mountain Dew or
something braid Blast Mountain Dew I'm
sorry it's Jimmy Neutron Oh I thought
you were I thought you were joining the
joke but you were just not understanding
it I see now yeah I'm not understanding
it I don't know I sound very drunk there
that was nice
what do you mean that's how you always
sound
thanks man you're welcome I'll be here
to support you okay I have an idea to
solve the the disturbing The Nest
problem I built a door on the second
floor and so I partitioned off an area
hey I'm listening listening my idea was
too much for him to handle that was just
a bad series of events for me but it's a
good idea Mark great idea thank you I
love it
keep doing that but yeah you get what
I'm saying it probably will work yeah
maybe
yeah
all right anytime I have a good idea in
the future you got to make that noise so
I know this is a certainty of it if you
don't say that I know I'm I'm a yeah
you're way off base way off base Mark I
got you something oh yeah oh man that's
so sweet oh babe babe right behind you
on the ground what'd you get me oh
another freaking shoe
wow oh in the shoes
hey guys do we have a research table we
do yeah work on the racer my God the the
the the what is this the port side of
the vessel or the starboard side is
extended pretty hefty
that's a long starboard
yes but you see it's all part of our
master plan
uh
go on that's as far as I got with the
plan all right I don't even want to use
these shoes because with the other crop
Luts I can plop down one water for three
I have to individually water these
I hate them too possibly more than you
do oh more and better than you is that
depressing to have someone to hate more
than you hate
I don't know maybe it's not quite
working I guess what I'm doing is I'm
making a chicken coop right I'm making a
Bird Coop
are you asking us what you're doing I'm
talking out loud uh okay okay
I'm a Fool why would you get there
I'm Just a Fool incoming shark
I'm stuck in the thing I got it I'm
dying of hunger oops
there's a cooked salmon on the grill oh
I had food the problem was my own all
right
okay so this didn't quite work but if I
give it more space
oh it's like the shark is destroying our
upstairs uh we got no probably not one
of those oh my God I let the Nets
accumulate look how much net stuff we
got it's all plastic the ocean is filled
with plastic we actually have kind of a
lot of metal and stuff that's great yeah
mainly what we need is to to accumulate
planks I think at the moment yeah those
always just never enough do you need any
Mark I have like a stack no I'm okay I'm
all right I'm I'm good
I got enough there's a wait what look to
the look to the off the port Corner oh
big big island oh it's a big island
[Applause]
guide us guide us I am so we are turned
we're turnt we're turned dude I'm sorry
the shark is here why is that and fell
off the raft for like two seconds
and the shark was like I do that would
happen calculated all right chicken coop
is going up watch this genius
but I'm over here
ow the shark is literally stalking me
waiting for me to do this I don't like
it all right chicken coop has been made
oh this was not as good of a thing as I
thought it would be oh are you doing out
there Bob good good if I get bit one
more time I think I'm dead
okay and then there's a shark will have
fallen into my trap oh he he didn't
foresee what I foreseen thought I for
suit I foresoft it all right don't go
into the chicken coop it's off limits
and you guys got one of them Scoops well
it Scoops us in a direction we means to
go in yeah I got the Scoops I got the
scoops
I've been known to get Scoops from time
to time from various locations
wait why don't we have a cooking pot
made we've got everything to make a
cooking pot I don't know I'm not a
cooker or a maker I'm a fisherman man I
don't know all right yeah that's my job
me is everything that's not fishing or
dying why is that happening
yeah what's wrong me I is a problem here
do I have a problem yes who drank all
the water and didn't refill it I've been
working on it it's not my job
you're with everything
they're dying to sharks like Bob's job I
haven't died a single
yeah a single time to always be dying
the Sharks I've never died adding of
hunger before I was dying of shark
s so take that I was born dying I'm
hungry I died so long ago inside guys
we're right by the Trading Post here too
we might need to all become Fishermans
we gotta figure out bait guys from The
Trading Post you guys Vine goo do I need
to cook it there's no goo but there's
some vines that can be cooked
something about this catfish so I can
put this uh other thing on the grill
excellent all right excellent excellent
did you want it Mark no no no I am good
I'm okay now there's a salmon cooking or
something I've literally been sustaining
myself on pure BT goodness I feel like
because I've been cooking fish and stuff
in the grill and I've been letting you
guys have it you know it's a favor to
you you should feel good and he wasn't
complaining he was just saying
I'm saying eat my cooking damn it no uh
he would if it was edible oh
all right I'm gonna go see what's going
on at the Trading Post uh
the trading what the trading posts
all the training it's like the creepy
pasta for trading posts the trading post
stuff all right you can buy simple
fishing bait here for
a trash oh God I forgot about trash
cubes right and the trash can does not
make it the trash can just throws stuff
away oh we need a recycler which is like
a thing you need a battery for it's like
we're not even close to having that
never mind there's a bunch of great
resources around the island guys wow
can't we make a lot of that stuff
already we don't know the recycler is
like a recipe you get from a specific
Island you have to visit I think it
might be this one
could be this one